the investigation into how that fire
killed shea is ongoing
a lot of questions not a lot of answers
thank you for joining us
at six o'clock i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez the i-team's david
charns has been digging into just
exactly what happened he's live in
downtown las vegas tonight outside of
zappos headquarters
with more information and of course
that's the company that tony shea used
to run
david
and denise tony shea just meant so much
to downtown las vegas and his former
employees here at zappos i want to show
you the memorial that's been set up here
some candles balloons and cards tonight
we're learning his official cause of
death is smoke inhalation
and radio calls between firefighters are
helping piece
some of this puzzle together five
hundred people for a fire inside of a
house
one person barricaded inside of a room
the first sign of trouble came at 3 30
in the morning
firefighters called to this waterfront
connecticut home for a man stuck inside
a burning shed
that's attached to the exterior of the
house and the male is there
inside he's not answering the door
according to real estate records the
home has guest quarters in the basement
with a fireplace
kitchen and attached shed which exits to
a pool area
it's not clear if shea was barricaded in
the shed as radio transmissions indicate
or if he was somehow stuck inside fire
officials tell the i-team they had to
force their way
in to pull shea out and they say others
in the house
were able to escape we have one victim
being pulled from the fire now
unresponsive shea was later transferred
to a burn center in another part of the
state
the i-team has confirmed the home is
owned by rachel brown
a long time zappos employee records show
brown bought the house this past
august and according to those radio
calls it does appear the fire began
in the basement where according to
records there's a fireplace
but right now it's unclear how that fire
started or how shea became trapped
inside that storage area
video from in front of the house monday
shows no visible damage
in a car parked in the driveway
now we did reach out to brown and we
have not heard back the medical examiner
in connecticut tells me that shea's
death has been ruled accidental
but they are waiting for some tests to
come back
and that is standard procedure live in
downtown las vegas tonight i'm david
chong
news now and david are those tests
standard procedure yeah
they are so in any sort of accidental
death or
death where there needs to be some more
investigation
they'll send out those blood tests to an
outside company
technically takes just a couple more
days to get that information
but any medical examiner is going to
want that information as part of their
investigation and also
to have on a person's death certificate
so it could be a couple more weeks
before we have that information